during the day the brain
you know I think the thing about that is
that um I think that it just it always
depends on where you're at in your life
I mean I think there's going to be
moments where you're like God if I had
only done this this way or that way and
I think you know now I'm kind of at the
point where I really see who I am and
you know I think once you kind of really
get a pulse on who you are you start to
realize like you couldn't have really
done anything differently you know I
mean yeah you know I think if you're
sitting there you're like I wish I could
have done this or I wish I would have
done this but you know those decisions
are are who you are you know so it's
like you kind of move on with you know
there's a kind of a realization alike
well no I would have never done that
that's not like that's not who I am you
know I am I mean I've kind of gone about
things the way that makes sense to me
and I think the more comfortable you are
with your path you know I think
artistically the more interesting the
work becomes so that's kind of where I'm
at